The Joe Rogan Experience that's the
other thing that Bob said that I thought
was really fascinating was that there
was some documentation that they were uh
showing him that claimed that we are the
product of accelerated Evolution he was
shown a lot of [ __ ] and he doesn't like
talking about it because he doesn't know
if it's just total [ __ ] nonsense
right you know he is sure that they
showed him [ __ ] just to see if he'd
[ __ ] say crazy [ __ ]
right see if he talked all he all he
cares about is the is what he saw what
he knows is real
but if if you do just talk with them
privately they did show him
you know a photograph of an autopsy of a
being with a singular organ
they told him that yeah the human genome
had been altered you know I'm just all
sorts of crazy [ __ ] and he just has no
idea if it's true or if it's
the whole thing is so it's so wild
I just wish you know if Bob's lying my
God what a great liar he's amazing at it
right and he's been telling the same lie
for 30 plus years and then there's
elements of it that how would he know
that like how would he know about
Element 115 I mean Element 115 when he
was talking about it was theoretical
yeah he got lucky he's a lucky he's the
luckiest guy he always chooses [ __ ] that
ends up being [ __ ] right I know you
know gravity waves and like you know how
these crap like look man explain the one
element 115 to people because people who
don't know what we're talking about that
haven't seen the documentary or haven't
seen the podcast we did together
so so the way Bob understood it was that
there's he was working on Power and
propulsion right so of one of these we
call them flying saucers you know
[ __ ] alien vehicle that looked like
this one exactly exactly yeah and um you
know even like Aerospace people are like
well
if if you know it's the most ingenious
thing is the way he described it powered
you know people are compressed by it I'm
like maybe that's just what he saw
anyway so the 115 was the power source
he said and basically you know you put
it in and it it releases anti-matter and
creates a gravity propulsion a gravity a
gravitational field and then you had a
directional three-directional emitters
look that's how they think these things
operate traveling faster than the speed
of sound with no Sonic Boom all you know
trans medium all domain these things
seem to defy
typical propulsion it's not outside of
the realm of what we understand it's
outside of the realm of what we can
replicate now
one day we might catch up
and this element 115 that Bob talked
about powering this spaceship was only
theoretical back in the late 1980s when
he first started discussing it right we
hadn't synthesized it yet right well it
wasn't a synthesizing it was uh it was
created by a particle accelerator right
exactly so it really it was detected
because it was I think it was but we
smashed right so we kind of sent
something that we smashed particles
together and then we're like oh for like
a second there it was yeah I think it's
a fraction yeah and Bob always said that
if he's right if it was 115 that's how
he understood it to be if he's right
then we will someday you know be able to
make a nominal amount of it that will be
stable
that that's you know what he says
you got another one of those yeah yeah
all right here we go
it never ends yeah it never ends it is
interesting I just like
until something actually happens and my
thought is like when something actually
happens how will people handle it UFO
whistleblower could get immunity under
new amendments so this is what you were
talking about yeah
yeah
yeah
absolutely and I mean the thing is I I
know some of the people doing this and
they're like you know they want some
nominations man you know who should talk
to them
well you got your own [ __ ] logo
thanks brother yeah these are uh
Foundation cigar JRE cigars they're good
shout out to my friend Nick from
Foundation cigars too hooked me up with
that cabinet
got a full humidor up in this [ __ ] now
wow
thank you
um so uh
so this element 115. yeah this is uh
proven by a particle accelerator and Bob
lazar's claim was that they had a stable
um amount of this element 115 that had
come from this other place and did they
know where this other place was where
this element 115 supposedly had come
from what another planet yeah I mean
again this is like what he was told so
he's kind of allergic to but um you know
he said that the documents said Zeta
reticuli like you know uh I guess a
binary star system or something that's
what we're in the documents now if
that's true or not look remember he
thought it was the U.S he thought this
vehicle was ours right and then he until
he walked inside of it that's his whole
thing it blew him away
you know it's hard to buy what someone
like Bob is telling you if you don't
know the person
you see people in their lives man
like what do you imagine being him
that actually happening to you and then
you having to go back to reality
right and tell people or not tell people
just live your life
and have the burden of this information
the burden of this thought just uh turn
upside down the other way
there you go flip the top I gotta flip
the top there you go and then pull down
I mean
the burden of that kind of information
when even discussing it you seem like
such a psycho
you know yeah most people almost
instantaneously other than a real
journalist like George Knapp most people
are going to think you're out of your
[ __ ] mind yeah they just dismiss you
yeah
why would you why would you even do it
like what would be your motivation
what would you get out of that well his
motivation was he was seriously worried
that they were going to take him out
yeah because he knew so much and uh they
had cut off of his for folks who don't
know the whole story
just give you a brief synopsis what
happened was Bob allegedly was working
on back engineering these aircrafts
these vehicles these spaceships and uh
in doing so you have to have a very high
level of clearance well with that high
level of clearance comes complete
government surveillance so they monitor
your phone calls monitor everything
turns out Bob's wife was having an
affair so they don't tell Bob that his
wife's have an affair but they cut off
his job they're like you're too you did
too much of a potential to be
emotionally unstable we can't have you
working on these top secret super
sensitive things yeah it's logical yeah
while your life is probably gonna fall
apart bad [ __ ] yeah so he doesn't know
this and so he's they don't give him any
information so he freaks out and so he
starts telling his friends he's like
come with me I'll show you the launch
I'm not lying people forget that yes he
he went out and he showed people a craft
that didn't look like any normal craft
come up right when he said it would yeah
over a base it wasn't even known then
really well and a sub base an area not
Area 51 proper again he's the luckiest
[ __ ] in the world he did it
three weekends in a row till he got
caught right so it's just like man every
time you try to call [ __ ] on him I
tried so hard on so many things people
think I'm just some [ __ ] believer I'm
not bro the only thing that people have
ever called [ __ ] on him is that he
said he might have seen an actual alien
but he said well he was walking down a
hallway and looked through one of those
little tiny Windows that's in a door you
know those little tiny like uh 12-inch
Square Windows and he peered in it
quickly as he was walking by and it
seemed like there was a small thing that
was sitting on a chair and there's
people standing over it but he doesn't
know if it was a doll he doesn't know if
it was and so in his mind he's like [ __ ]
did I see an alien like what the [ __ ]
but he can't go back it's not like
everything's if you work on top secret
stuff apparently everything's very
compartmentalized like the people that
work on Metallurgy don't have access to
the people that work on propulsion that
don't have access to the people that if
there is a biological entity that they
examine it which frustrated the [ __ ] out
of him right because that's not how you
do science it's not how you do science
right yeah he says I wasn't the most
qualified person to be there maybe they
hired me because they could easily
dismiss me
you know he's like why didn't we have
better people on this you know people
that were more so he was really
frustrated and he said to me like he
thought it was a crime against the
scientific Community you know to if they
have this stuff like he says you know he
says it was a crime and you know he he
talks about that thing through the
window he's so funny about it you know I
sat him down for long you know many
sessions long really trying to get at
him get it out of them yeah he goes You
know Jeremy I think they were just
obsessed with measurements I go what do
you mean and he's like well look there
was somebody in something in a chair but
it was small maybe they were trying to
just measure it to see if it would fit
in a craft so that's how he kind of
gets around like did he see something or
not he doesn't know like it could have
been a doll that that's what he struck
did that was roughly the same height as
these things were he just doesn't want
to go there right and so these creatures
that were in this vehicle if there were
were creatures in this vehicle there
were three seats yeah and he estimated
they had to be how big your typical like
what you think of as a little gray alien
man three four feet right he said they
looked like they were made for children
hmm
the seats yeah and so look and every
time I try to be like dismissed by
myself there's something that Creeps in
my mind I'm like hold on hold on like I
find out
that he that he was telling the truth
like recently I had it verified that you
know he did work at error 51 like I know
I know I had a guy I found the guy after
30 years that when he wouldn't talk with
George the guy that did a security
clearance I found him I talked to him
multiple times about this and he did
clearance for Bob for the test site
but even more recently
from people that have positioned to
access that information it was confirmed
I just want you to know
he worked out there now I have people
that were out there that saw him
on a Janet flight
Bob worked out there and a Janet flight
is those on unmarked planes that would
leave
from the Vegas airport and head into
area 51. that's right
and and uh you know here's the deal man
like it's the cumulative evidence about
Bob that I you know as a friend of his
not like I you know I have no reason to
doubt him and all the evidence tells me
that it happened exactly like he said
and he's explaining it to the best of
his ability and to his own detriment
actually before coming on your show man
he's probably the most hated dude for
some reason people go crazy about him
either love him or hate him well I think
your documentary turned a lot of
people's opinions about him as well
thank you but then having him on I mean
some people still call [ __ ] they
think like his migraines that's so
convenient oh come on you saw yeah but
he was having him he was having him in
the green room before we started going
on he was very nervous about doing it of
course man he's been beat up his whole
life about this [ __ ] also I gave him
McDonald's before I think his life was
super pissed at me and I was gonna give
him a salad no he gets really like
crushing migraines but you know people
that are going to call [ __ ] on that
we're talking about [ __ ] UFOs if
you're gonna call [ __ ] on a migraine
what are you even listening for I I
didn't feel like it was [ __ ] it was
it felt like the whole thing was
it was uncomfortable for him for sure
but it didn't seem like he was lying but
you know look some people that are
really good at Liars but usually when
you're really good at lying you lie
about a lot of stuff yeah that's the
thing there's a consistency in people's
lives and the deeper I got in to
chilling with his mom chilling with his
family chilling with friends that have
known him forever new friends every
single person
and he doesn't talk about UFOs by the
way like all this he never talks about
that just normal life situations
the the one thing they all said to me
Bob wouldn't waste his [ __ ] time with
making up a story and he'd probably make
up a better one that in the rest he
would and Bob always says that he goes
man I wish I could fill the voids for
people he goes it's a horrible [ __ ]
story but it happens to be what happened
right if I was making one up he goes man
I got some other cool ideas like you
know what I mean right of course of
course and also it's like if you're a
liar you generally lie a lot like liars
don't just like one time that's your
life and then you catch him they're
inconsistent like he was lying long
before there was an internet I mean
excuse me he was telling the story long
before the there was an internet so if
he was lying like in the late 80s like
there there would be inconsistencies in
his story yeah he would forget how he
said it he would [ __ ] something up or
dude the research I did for this for the
documentary like I I told him you got to
give me full access to your life dude
like boxes whatever don't open let me
get all your tapes everything
I was so shocked like
people if they're trying to hide
something they're real careful around
you you know just that's not that was
not my experience but here's my other
thing it's like do we have to believe
any one single person
to understand that this is no yeah this
is a real thing no but he's one of the
more interesting cases because if he's
telling the truth that means that the
government has been working on these
things for decades and decades and that
they have gotten this
they've gotten themselves in this pickle
where they can't publicly disclose what
they know and what they have access to
because they've had all these people
work on these things secretly and they
sort of have a long history of hiding
information right